[Musique]
millions d'électeurs appelés parlement
européen issu d'ici dix ans ces neuf
pays et allemagne la belgique le
danemark la france la grande bretagne
l'irlande l'italie le luxembourg les
pays-bas totalisent environ 250 millions
d'habitants le plus peuplé d'entre eux
et l'allemagne et c'est en irlande que
l'on trouve le plus de jeunes de moins
de 15
puisque seul le suffrage universel
je pense avoir vous voter il faut avoir
un peu plus de 18 ans et avoir la
nationalité française
les ingénieurs sont chez tous les toutes
les personnes qui toutes les personnes
majeures c'est à seynod strictement
aucune idée
est ce que tes parents votent aux
élections tu peux me donner les noms des
neuf pays qui constitue actuellement le
marché commun
[Musique]
en irlande
france la belgique sont la belgique la
france le pays bas grande bretagne et
mais groupe est ce qu'on parle beaucoup
de l'europe dans votre école non très
peu c'est combien de députés seront élus
au total ce nouveau parlement européen
n'a jamais entendu parler comment
s'appellent les traités qui a donné
naissance à l'europe
[Musique]
tu serais partisan de réunir tous les
pays d'europe en un seul pays non et
pourquoi parce qu'on n'a pas la même vie
de vivre
je prends un exemple l'angleterre
elle mange pas aux heures comme nous et
puis ça ne sera pas pareil qu'on
n'entende pas assez les mêmes conditions
y en a qui ont imposé leur loi
oui il y aurait moins de guerre louis
parce que oui je suis pas moi on y
ressent le monde par exemple de coeur et
l'économique poison non mais je connais
rien et comme parce que comme s'il y
avait la guerre
ce serait qu'on serait plus tôt mende et
et plus ça nous éviterait donc de
recourir aux autres pays comme on a fait
un 1939 ben non ça sera pas une bonne
chose parce que ça serait difficile de
se comprendre parce que les gens
n'auraient même n'aurait pas les mêmes
opinions mais parce que chaque pays par
ce ver est arrêté puis puis par un raid
l'heure malgré tout quelles sont les
grandes différences qu'il ya entre toi
un jeune italien jeune allemand un jeune
anglais au pyla partout carte à la main
sinon tu te sens comme eux est ce que la
langue n'est pas un obstacle
non parce que au fur et à mesure qu'on
parlera on réussira quant à se
comprendre même il ya les ges en a
beaucoup qui servent des gestes donc
tout le monde se servira et ensuite tout
le monde se comprendra est-ce que c'est
très important les frontières sais tu
pourquoi il ya des frontières
d'où ses pinceaux des pays bon moi je
trouve que c'est complètement inutile
parce que bon c'est peut-être utile si
pour une chose je me contredis pour les
rentrées de droit où n'importe quoi des
choses mauvaises à l'europe
s'il n'y avait pas de frontières toit
ont été commises à faire du trafic
communal l'europe de demain l'europe de
20 ans tu le vois comment ben je le
vends avec des enfants plus malheureux
toutes les personnes soit égard à la
même hauteur
tu la vois les enfants plus malheureux
ou plus heureux [ __ ] je vois
des renforts de police parce que je
trouve que bombay cia pas s'il ya pas de
renfort on sera beaucoup plus nombreux
jeudi aura eu cette union donc on pourra
mieux s'entendre par les forces de
police puis donc s'il ya un là on pourra
s'arranger par la parole
je vois aussi tous les gens c'est mais
partir la main dans la main dans un
projet donné des idées les agrandir
et puis enfin les en faire part à tout
le monde qu'elle soit même mise dans
d'autres d'autres régions du monde
et puis donc voilà tout un travail
[Musique]